far cry 6 has been delayed cd projekt
red weighs in
on why cyberpunk was delayed again and
bethesda's todd howard comments on
whether or not he thinks elder scrolls 6
will be an xbox exclusive
there have been some huge gaming news
stories today so let's jump in
[Music]
ubisoft has just delayed two of its
biggest upcoming games
far cry 6 and rainbow six quarantine
will no longer release in the current
fiscal year
that means the earliest we'll see either
game is april
2021 and sometime between that date and
march 2022
as you'd expect the delays are due to
production challenges related to work
from home
rainbow six quarantine was already
delayed once alongside
gods and monsters and watch dogs legion
gods and monsters was actually renamed
immortals phoenix rising and will be out
on december 3rd
and watch dogs legion is available as of
today so go check out our review
cyberpunk recently got pushed into
december and now we might know why
on an investor call cd projekt red's
adam kaczynski said
the studio is still optimizing the game
on current gen consoles
the game is ready for the pc and runs
great on the next-gen consoles
and could be shipped on the scheduled
date on those platforms however
even though the game has been certified
on the current gens by both sony and
microsoft
some very final optimization processes
for such a massive and complex game
require a bit of additional time
so it seems cdpr weren't happy with how
cyberpunk runs
on the ps4 and xbox one cd projekt red
will also be releasing free
next-gen upgrades next year so you can
pick up the game on the current gen and
make the jump later if you wish
and if you're itching for more cyberpunk
while you wait we've got a ton of lore
videos up on the channel for you right
now
last month xbox bought bethesda and all
anyone has been asking since then
is what that means for exclusivity of
bethesda franchises
going forward there were comments about
series like elder scrolls and fallout
becoming xbox exclusives as a result of
the acquisition but that might not come
to pass
at least for the elder scrolls vi
bethesda's creative director todd howard
said
it's hard to imagine that happening
obviously that is not a final decision
but it's encouraging if you're still
playing on pc
or on playstation bethesda will still be
publishing its own games according to
howard the partnership with xbox seems
to be more about xbox services like game
pass
quote subscriptions came along and now
you see the quality and
investment in dramas or historical
fiction series
that's where creators are able to go and
create these things people want
and it makes sense for everybody the
people paying the bills
the people creating it and the people
consuming it that's what we see
happening with games with things like
game pass this week on generation next
we're answering all your questions about
the playstation 5 so make sure you check
it out on gamespot.com
or on youtube.com gamespot i'm on
twitter at lucy james games and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you